COUNTRY?
ANSWERS.
THAT IS IN TONIGHT’S
BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
♫
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, WE START
TONIGHT WITH BREAKING NEWS
AND DETAILS ABOUT THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THIS
HORRIFIC TRAGIC FLORIDA HIGH
SCHOOL SHOOTING.
NOW THE 19-YEAR-OLD GUNMAN
NIKOLAS CRUZ, HE HAS NOW
CONFESSED TO SLAUGHTERING 17
INNOCENT PEOPLE AND WOUNDING
CRUZ IS ALSO TELLING
INVESTIGATORS DETAILS OF THE
SINISTER ATTACK.
HE SHOT STUDENTS IN THE
HALLWAY.
HE FIRED INTO FIVE SEPARATE
CLASSROOMS AND CRUZ ALSO
CONFESSED TO AUTHORITIES
THAT HE HAD EXTRA AMMUNITION
IN HIS BACKPACK.
WE’RE ALSO LEARNING
DISTURBING NEW DETAILS OF
MISSED WARNING SIGNS IN WHAT
IS NOW ONE OF THE WORST MASS
SHOOTINGS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
ALL OF THE RED FLAGS WERE
THERE BUT TRAGICALLY,
NIKOLAS CRUZ WAS ABLE TO
COMMIT THIS HEINOUS ACT.
NOW, THE FBI IS, IN FACT,
CONFIRMING TONIGHT THAT IN
SEPTEMBER, A YOUTUBE USER,
WITH THE NAME NIKOLAS CRUZ
SPELLED THE NAME THE SAME
WAY AS THE SHOOTER WAS
REPORTED TO THE BUREAU FOR
WRITING, QUOTE:  I’M GOING
TO BE A PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL
SHOOTER.
THE MAN WHO REPORTED THE
COMMENTS SAID THAT THE FBI
VISITED HIM THE FOLLOWING
DAY BUT THE BUREAU IS SAYING
TODAY THAT IT COULD NOT BE
DETERMINED THE TIME, THE
LOCATION, AND ACTUAL
IDENTITY OF WHO POSTED THE
COMMENT.
OUR OWN CATHERINE HERRIGE AS
SHE NOTED EARLIER TODAY ALL
THE FBI WOULD HAVE HAD TO DO
IS TRACE THE IP ADDRESS
WHICH IS A ROUTINE PRACTICE
TO DETERMINE THE LOCATION OF
THE INDIVIDUAL.
FOR SOME REASON, IT DIDN’T
HAPPEN IN THIS CASE.
NOW, THE MAYOR OF BROWARD
COUNTY IS SAYING THAT
NIKOLAS CRUZ WAS BEING
TREATED AT A MENTAL HEALTH
CLINIC BUT STOP SEEKING
TREATMENT MORE THAN A YEAR
AGO.
AND AUTHORITIES ARE
DESCRIBING HIS SOCIAL MEDIA
POST AS BEYOND DISTURBING.
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE PICTURES.
YOU CAN SEE THE SUSPECT.
IS HE SEEN POSING WITH GUNS
AND NYESTE AND EVEN DEAD
ANIMALS.
FORMER CLASSMATES OF CRUZ
SAY HE WAS A LONER, HE WAS
OBSESSED WITH FIREARMS.
HE LIKED TO SHOW OFF
PICTURES OF ALL OF HIS
WEAPONS.
NOW THE MIAMI HERALD IS
REPORTING THAT CRUZ HAD BEEN
SUSPENDED FOR FIGHTING AND
HAVING AMMUNITION IN HIS
BACKPACK AND CRUZ WAS THEN
LATER EXPELLED FOR
DISCIPLINARY REASONS AND
ATTENDING A SCHOOL IN
BROWARD COUNTY FOR AT RISK
STUDENTS.
CRUZ ALSO HAD PROBLEMS AT
HOME.
BOTH PARENTS ADOPTED HIM AND
HIS BROTHER ARE DEAD.
HIS MOTHER PASSED AWAY IN
NOVEMBER.
NOW THE SUSPECT WAS STAYING
WITH A FRIEND’S FAMILY AND
THERE WERE ALSO REPORTS OF
NIKOLAS CRUZ HAVING TIES TO
A FLORIDA BASED WHITE
SUPREMACIST GROUP.
LAW ENFORCEMENT SAID EARLIER
TODAY THAT THEY HAVEN’T SEEN
ANY OF THOSE CONNECTIONS.
WE’LL CONTINUE TO MONITOR.
WHAT’S ALSO VERY TROUBLING
TONIGHT IS HOW STUDENTS ARE
DESCRIBING THEIR FORMER
CLASSMATE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY SAY ABOUT
THE SHOOTER, NIC LAZARUS
CRUZ.
LET’S WATCH.
>> HE DEFINITELY HAD JUST
SOME THINGS A LITTLE OFF
ABOUT HIM.
IT WAS JUST MORE OR LESS
THAT HE WAS AGGRESSIVE AND
QUIET AND SHY ABOUT WHEN HE
GOT AGGRESSIVE.
>> HIS PERSONALITY WAS LIKE
VERY DIFFERENT.
>> HE WAS A BIT OFF.
HE WOULD LIKE CURSE RANDOMLY
IN THE MIDDLE OF LUNCH.
YOU KNOW, HE WOULD JUST LIKE
SCREAM OUT RANDOM CURSE
WORDS.
HE ALWAYS SEEMED A LITTLE
BIT OFF, YOU KNOW.
JUST SOMETHING WAS WRONG
WITH HIM.
>> A LOT OF LIKE CRAZY STUFF
THAT HE DID.
JUST NOT -- HE GOT KICKED
OUT OF SCHOOL MOST OF THE
TIME.
HONESTLY PEOPLE WERE SAYING
IT WAS GOING TO BE HIM.
JOKED LIKE THAT THAT HE
WOULD BE THE ONE TO SHOOT UP
THE SCHOOL.
IT TURNS OUT EVERYONE
PREDICTED IT.
THAT’S CRAZY.
>> Sean: JUST LIKE WITH
OTHER MASS SHOOTERS.
THERE WERE SIGNS, THERE WERE
WARNINGS OF MENTAL, SOCIAL,
EMOTIONAL PROBLEMS.
BUT ALL THE PIECES WERE
NEVER PUT TOGETHER TO
PREVENT THIS TRAGEDY FROM
HAPPENING.
AND LIKE WITH MANY OTHER
SHOOTINGS AND TERRORIST
ATTACKS, NIKOLAS CRUZ WAS
TELEGRAPHING HIS ATTENTIONS
ALL OVER SOCIAL MEDIA.
ASIDE FROM THE OBVIOUS FACT
THAT ANYONE THAT WOULD
COMMIT THESE HORRIBLE ACTS
OF EVIL AND VIOLENCE ARE
COMPLETELY DERANGED, THE ONE
COMMONALITY BETWEEN THE
GUNMAN AND PARKLAND, FLORIDA
TO SOUTER LAND, TEXAS TO THE
CHURCH IN SOUTH CAROLINA,
SANDY HOOK, VIRGINIA TECH
ARE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
MENTAL ILLNESS.
DURING AN ADDRESS TO THE
NATION EARLIER TODAY THE
PRESIDENT OFFERED HIS
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES AND
HIGHLIGHTED THIS ISSUE OF
MENTAL HEALTH.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE COMFORT THE GRIEVING
AND THE WOUNDED.
AND WE HURT FOR THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY OF PARKLAND,
FLORIDA THAT IS NOW IN SHOCK
AND PAIN AND SEARCHING FOR
ANSWERS.
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT, FIRST
RESPONDERS, AND TEACHERS WHO
RESPONDED SO BRAVELY IN THE
FACE OF DANGER, WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COURAGE.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH STATE AND LOCAL LEADERS
TO HELP SECURE OUR SCHOOLS
AND TACKLE THE DIFFICULT
ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH.
LATER THIS MONTH I WILL BE
MEETING WITH THE NATION’S
GOVERNORS AND ATTORNEY
GENERALS.
WE’RE MAKING OUR SCHOOLS AND
OUR CHILDREN SAFER WILL BE
OUR TOP PRIORITY.
IT IS NOT ENOUGH TO SIMPLY
TAKE ACTIONS THAT MAKE US
FEEL LIKE WE ARE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
WE MUST ACTUALLY MAKE THAT
>> Sean: PROFOUND WORDS FROM
THE PRESIDENT SAYING IT’S
NOT ENOUGH TO FEEL BETTER.
IT’S GOT TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
NOW, HE IS ALSO, THE
PRESIDENT IS, PLANNING TO
VISIT PARKLAND, FLORIDA AND
OFFER COMFORT AND SUPPORT TO
THE COMMUNITY.
DETAILS HAVE NOT YET BEEN
FINALIZED.
ALSO PREDICTABLY WITHIN
HOURS DEMOCRATS AND THE
LIBERAL MEDIA RACE TO
POLITICIZE A TRAGEDY AND TRY
TO BLAME, BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
REPUBLICANS.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK.
>> STEP UP.
BE A MAN, AND TALK ABOUT IT
AND STOP THINKING ABOUT THE
NRA AND YOUR NEXT CAMPAIGN
DONATION.
JUST STOP.
EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT YOU’RE
DOING.
AND IT’S TIME.
THAT DOES IT FOR US THIS
MORNING.
STEFANIE RAÚL PICKS UP THE
COVERAGE RIGHT NOW.
>> THANKS SO MUCH, MIKA,
THANKS, JOE.
MARCO RUBIO YOU TONIGHT HAVE
TO STEP UP AND BE A MAN.
STEP UP AND BE A HUMAN.
>> WORDS OF CONTEMPLATION,
TALK ABOUT MENTAL HEALTH ARE
COMPLETE NOT ENOUGH.
THEY MUST BE FOLLOWED BY
REAL ACTION.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO LEAD OR
GET OUT OF THE WAY.
>> PEOPLE HAVE GOT TO SAY
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
WE ARE NOT CONTINUING WITH
ALL THESE MASSACRES.
AND WE HAVE GOT TO HAVE THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE HALLS OF
GOVERNMENT RESPOND TO THAT.
>> Sean: THIS HAS HAPPENED
WITH REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATIONS, UNDER
DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATIONS.
BUT WHAT YOU SEE THERE IS
SHAMEFUL.
IT’S DISGUSTING.
BUT IT’S NOT SURPRISING
BECAUSE IT’S SO PREDICTABLE.
IT HAPPENS EVERY SINGLE TIME
THERE IS A SHOOTING.
HOLLYWOOD CELEBRITIES, THEY
ARE ALL SO QUICK TO POST
THEIR HATEFUL MESSAGES, OF
COURSE, AIMED AT THE
PRESIDENT REPUBLICANS ON
TWITTER.
START WITH CHELSEA HANDLER,
QUOTE TO THEY HAVE TO ELECT
CANDIDATES NOT FUNDED BY THE
NRA IN NOVEMBER.
WE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ELECT
CANDIDATES WON’T ALLOW KIDS
TO GO TO SCHOOL AND GET
SHOT.
DISGUSTING HOW MANY TIMES
THIS HAS HAPPENED AND
REPUBLICANS DO NOTHING.
YOU ALL HAVE BLOOD ON YOUR
HANDS.
BETTE MIDLER, ANOTHER SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
THIS IN FLORIDA.
CONGRATS TO THE SPINELESS
COWARDS TO HO DO NOTHING TO
HELP US END THIS HORRIFIC
EPIDEMIC IE CONGRESS.
KIDS ARE BEING KILLED IN
SCHOOLS, CHURCHES, CONCERTS.
LET’S DO SOMETHING.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN KIDS
ARE BEING KILLED IN SCHOOLS
AND CHURCHES AND CONCERTS.
LET’S NOT DO ONE SINGLE
THING, #BLOOD ON YOUR HANDS
AT G.O.P. AND AT NRA.
AUTHOR STEVEN KING WRITES
BROWARD SCHOOL SHOOTING,
THERE WILL BE PRAYERS FROM
BLABBER MOUTH DON, PENCE IN THE
GRINCH AND THEIR RIGHT WING
COHORTS.
THERE WILL BE NO CALL FOR
ANY SORT OF SANE GUN
REGULARS.
THEY WANT TO POINT FINGERS
AND BLAME AND USE ALL KINDS
OF VICIOUS RHETORIC IT NEVER
ACCOMPLISHES ANYTHING.
NOW, THEY SHOULDN’T BE WHAT
THESE TRAGEDIES ARE ABOUT
HERE.
HAVE YOU PEOPLE ROLLING OUT
THE SAME OLD TIRED TALKING
POINTS AND POLITICAL
ARGUMENTS.
LIBERALS THEY START BLAMING
THE WEAPON THAT THE SHOOTER
USED.
IN THIS CASE AN AR-15.
IF THEY WANT TO BAN AR-15
AND THESE MAD MEN THEY WILL
USE SOMETHING ELSE.
WE SAW THAT AT VIRGINIA TECH
WHERE A GUNMAN USED A PISTOL
AND KILLED 32 PEOPLE.
LOOK, LET’S GET THE
SOLUTIONS TONIGHT.
I HAVE BEEN IN RADIO FOR 30
YEARS IN MY LIFE.
THIS IS NOW MY 23RD YEAR AT
THE FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
I KNOW ALL OF THE TALKING
POINTS.
AND I KNOW IT’S ALL JUST
NOISE AND IT’S NOT GOING TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
HERE’S THE SIMPLE TRUTH.
YOU’RE NOT GOING TO CHANGE
PEOPLE’S MINDS WITH A
POLITICAL DEBATE, ESPECIALLY
AS IT RELATES TO THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
MY MIND IS NOT GOING TO BE
CHANGED.
I HAVE THOUGHT THIS THROUGH
ALL THESE YEARS IN MY LIFE.
I DOUBT CAN I CHANGE THE
MINDS OF ANY OF THESE
HOLLYWOOD LIBERALS AND THE
ANTI-SECOND AMENDMENT CROWD.
THE PROBLEM THIS COUNTRY IS
FACING RIGHT NOW IS SCHOOL
SAFETY.
NOW, WE CAN KEEP REPEATING
THE SAME TALKING POINTS AND
TALKING OVER EACH OTHER
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN
AFTER SOMETHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENS.
OR MAYBE IT’S TRYING TO
ACTUALLY FIND A SOLUTION TO
THIS PROBLEM.
THE CHILDREN OF THIS COUNTRY
DESERVE TO BE PROTECTED.
THEY DESERVE SAFE SCHOOLS.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID, NO
CHILD, NO TEACHER SHOULD
EVER BE IN DANGER IN AN
AMERICAN SCHOOL.
WE CAN ALL AGREE ON THAT.
NO PARENT SHOULD HAVE TO
FEAR FOR THEIR SON OR
DAUGHTERS WHEN THEY KISS
THEM GOODBYE IN THE MORNING.
I WANT TO LAY OUT A SOLUTION
THAT I THINK IS NOT
POLITICAL AND, FRANKLY, I
BELIEVE ANY REASONABLE
PERSON CAN AGREE ON.
THIS IS ABOUT THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF STUDENTS AND
CHILDREN IN OUR SCHOOLS.
AND EVERY SINGLE SCHOOL IN
THE COUNTRY IMMEDIATELY A
COMPREHENSIVE, THREAT
ASSESSMENT DONE BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS.
EVERY SCHOOL HAS A UNIQUE
SITUATION.
AND FOR THOSE THAT WILL SAY
OH, OH, WHERE ARE WE GOING
TO GET THE MONEY FOR THIS?
I WILL WOULD ARGUE IT’S
PROBABLY MORE THAN LIKELY
LOCAL POLICE, LOCAL FBI
WOULD BE HAPPY TO HELP
SCHOOLS FIGURE OUT THE BEST
PLAN OF ACTION TO PROTECT
THESE KIDS AND KEEP THEM
SAFE.
NOW, YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE TO
SECURE THE SCHOOL.
ALL POINTS OF ENTRY MUST BE
SECURE.
YOU HAVE GOT MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS A SYSTEM THAT
CONTROLS WHO IS GOING IN AND
OUT OF THE BUILDING.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT YOU
WILL NEED A STRONG, PHYSICAL
SECURITY PRESENCE.
AND YOU CAN START BY HIRING
TRAINED, ARMED, FORMER, OR
RETIRED POLICE OFFICERS,
TRAINED, ARMED, FORMER
RETIRED ARMED MILITARY
VETERANS.
OUR KIDS THE SAME SECURITY
THAT MOST POLITICIANS THAT
THEY GET.
LET’S GIVE THEM THE SAME
PROTECTION THAT ACTORS AND
ACTRESSES GET ON THE RED
CARPET WHEN THEY ARE AT THE
OSCARS AND PRETTY MUCH
EVERYWHERE ELSE THEY GO.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF RETIRED
OFFICERS.
PLENTY OF TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS.
PLENTY OF TRAINED MILITARY
GUYS.
THEY CAN CONCEAL THEIR
WEAPONS.
BUT THEIR VERY PRESENCE ALSO
WITH THE STRATEGY, STRATEGIC
PLAN, THAT IS PROPERLY
IMPLEMENTED WILL BRING ABOUT
A PROFOUND CHANGE.
PROBABLY DETRACTORS OUT
THERE SAY BUT, SEAN, PARK
LAND, FLORIDA HIGH SCHOOL
THEY HAD AN ARMED SECURITY
GUARD.
HERE’S THE THING.
THE SCHOOL HAS 3,000
STUDENTS.
IT’S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CAMPUSES IN FLORIDA.
YOU’RE GONNA NEED MORE THAN
ONE PERSON TO PROPERLY
ASSESS AND DETER ANY
POTENTIAL THREAT AT A
FACILITY THAT LARGE.
WE NEED ENOUGH PEOPLE TO
PROTECT EVERY SINGLE
BUILDING, EVERY POINT OF
ENTRY.
AND THE ENTIRE PERIMETER.
NOW, SOME OF YOU WILL ARGUE,
OKAY, THIS IS GOING TO COST
MONEY.
YOU’RE RIGHT.
MY ANSWER IS, YES.
BUT IS IT NOT WORTH EVERY
PENNY SO THAT WE NEVER EVER
HAVE TO TURN ON OUR TVS LIKE
YESTERDAY AND SEE THIS
UNFOLD EVER AGAIN LIKE WHAT
HAPPENED IN PARKLAND.
NOW, HERE IS ANOTHER POINT
ABOUT THE PLAN.
NOW, WE ALREADY KNOW IT
WORKS.
I HAVE BROADCAST FROM NEW
YORK CITY.
AND POST 9/11 YOU CANNOT
ENTER A SINGLE OFFICE
BUILDING WITHOUT A WORK I.D.
I HAVE A RADIO BUILDING I
ENTER.
I HAVE A TV BUILDING I
IF YOU ARE A VISITOR IN ANY
OF THESE BUILDINGS, YOU HAVE
TO PRESENT A VALID
IDENTIFICATION, OR ELSE YOU
ARE NOT GETTING IN.
AND HAVE YOU TO BE VOUCHED
FOR BY PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
SECURED AND ALREADY IN THE
BUILDING OR WORK IN THE
BUILDING.
EVERY STUDENT CAN HAVE THEIR
OWN VALID I.D. BEFORE
ENTERING THE SCHOOL AND ALSO
WHERE NEEDED METAL DETECTORS
WHICH HAVE ALREADY PROVEN TO
BE EFFECTIVE IN SOME SCHOOLS
IN THE COUNTRY.
HERE’S THE BOTTOM LINE, WE
ARE AT A CROSSROADS.
IT’S TIME TO EITHER STEP UP,
DO OUR JOB, CREATE SCHOOL
SAFETY THAT WILL WORK FOR
THESE KIDS.
GIVE THEM THE SAME SAFETY
OUR POLITICIANS, ACTORS,
ACTRESSES, AND FAMOUS PEOPLE
GET.
INSTEAD OF BRINGING OUT THE
SAME OLD TALKING POINTS AND
TRYING TO SCORE CHEAP
POLITICAL POINTS AND TRYING
TO OUTDO EACH OTHER WITH THE
SAME ARGUMENT, SAME ATTACKS,
NOBODY’S MINDS BEING CHANGED
MAYBE FOR ONCE WE CAN SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
THIS SHOULD BE ALL ABOUT
SOLUTIONS.
I’M NOT SAYING THIS PLAN IS
FLAWLESS.
NOTHING IS EVER GOING TO
STOP 100 PERCENT OF THESE
THINGS FROM HAPPENING.
THERE IS EVIL IN THE HEARTS
OF OTHER PEOPLE,
UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS WORLD.
BUT, WHY WOULDN’T WE TRY TO
DO EVERY SINGLE THING WE CAN
DO IN THIS CASE TO PREVENT
THESE TRAGEDIES FROM
OCCURRING.
AND MAKE THEM LESS DEADLY
IF, IN FACT, THEY DO HAPPEN.
HERE’S A SIMPLE TEST AND A
QUESTION FOR EVERYBODY
TONIGHT I THINK THEY CAN ASK
THEMSELVES.
IF GOD FORBID YOU EVER FOUND
YOURSELF IN ANY TYPE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE BUILDING AND
THAT BUILDING HAS AN ACTIVE
SHOOTER.
WOULD YOU PREFER TO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE TRAINED,
ARMED, RETIRED MILITARY AND
POLICE ALREADY ON SITE TO
GIVE YOU A FIGHTING CHANCE?
WOULD YOU WANT TO KNOW THAT
THERE WAS A COMPLETE THREAT
ASSESSMENT, SECURITY
ASSESSMENT ON THAT BUILDING
THAT WAS COMPLETED?
MY GUESS IS YOU PROBABLY.
WE HERE’S OUR FINAL POINT.
DEMOCRATS, THEY SAY GUN
CONTROL LEADS TO LESS
VIOLENCE.
WELL, IF THAT’S THE CASE, I
WOULD LIKE FOR THEM TO
EXPLAIN WHY CITIES WITH THE
HIGHEST MURDER RATES HAVE
THE STRICTEST GUN CONTROLS
AND RUN BY DEMOCRATS.
LOOK AT THESE STAT ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF MURDERS IN 2016.
ALL OF THESE CITIES HAVE
DEMOCRATIC MAYOR’S AND HAVE
BEEN RUN BY LIBERALS FOR
YEARS.
YET, THEIR CRACKDOWNS ON THE
SECOND AMENDMENT IT HAS DONE
NOTHING TO STOP VIOLENCE.
LIBERALS ALSO DON’T WANT YOU
TO KNOW ABOUT THESE SHOCKING
STATISTICS.
DURING THE OBAMA PRESIDENCY,
OVER 3900 MURDERS IN HIS
ADOPTIVE TOWN OF CHICAGO.
AND MORE THAN 18,000 PEOPLE
WHO WERE SHOT IN CHICAGO
JUST DURING THE LAST SIX
YEARS OF HIS PRESIDENCY.
DO YOU REMEMBER HEARING THIS
KIND OF OUTRAGE AND BLAME BY
THE LEFT ABOUT THE
OUT-OF-CONTROL VIOLENCE?
THAT’S ONE AMERICAN CITY.
AND LIBERALS ALSO LOVE TO
SAY THAT GIVING PEOPLE THE
RIGHT TO CARRY DOESN’T
PREVENT CRIME.
THE FIGURES SAY OTHERWISE.
LET’S TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF
THE CHARTS GIVEN TO US BY
AUTHOR MORE GUN LESS CRIMES.